[Music]
are you hot
burning Lisa does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he doesn't
play
sports my tenda is grave I talk to him I
wish I was with
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa
you hear that I'm sure it's the girl
next door she's very
odd your
H I can't believe you're here do you
like music I have the Cure oh not that
kind of cure they can't make you better
I mean they can but like emotionally no
don't cry your tears smell so
bad send it back need a
friend I love it it's not really my
style when you're in doubt L looks good
she could probably even do pageants if
she had
Congeniality your daughter is a little
psycho I open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
little I want to help you but Taffy says
it's a waste of time to try and fix
a he better just accept a guy's father
oh that's so cute to tell I have an idea
there are bad people out there who want
Lea it'll feel
good that hand is going to do terrible
things I'm
sorry you are being admitted impatient
lock
down I could get the clink for life or
the electric chair but I don't want to
die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of the
student I'm not making any more
comments you can talk to my lawyer
really hope this goth phase in
[Music]
soon
pap